In this case study, we
go back to the question
we continue asking: "what
do you want me to see?"
So sometimes when I'm asked
to help out with an image,
I have no idea what's
in store for me.
For example, the
first time I walked
through this particular lab, I
had no clue what to look for.
The researchers
suggested starting
with this set-up showing
part of their system, which
developed a more efficient
way of capturing and storing
energy.
For me, that set-up
just didn't convey
the excitement of the science.
But then as I turned
towards the chamber,
I saw where the solar
thermophotovoltaic device,
or STPV device, was
doing its thing.
The chamber was covered
with aluminum foil,
as many chambers are
in labs, I've noticed.
But I was able to focus my eye
on the window of the chamber.
It looked really
beautiful to me.
My initial image
was a mess at first,
a little too much going on.
So I decided to
simplify the idea,
as we continue talking about.
I deleted all that foil
and just concentrated
on the circular window
showing the device.
I then digitally
added a background
for a potential submission.
When I returned to the
lab a few days later,
with a different
device in the chamber,
I decided to add some
color by reflecting
an orange cloth I saw
hiding in the corner
somewhere in front of the
glass, and this time focusing
in on just the device
in the chamber.
I moved the camera closer,
shooting at around f/32.
Notice how the depth
of field is narrow
since I'm quite
close to the window.
I imagined what I was going
to do with the cropped,
focused section.
First, I overlaid it on an
image of the vacuum chamber
from before, as I shot before.
Then I decided to
try something else.
Using the single image
of the device again,
I digitally stretched
part of the image
to make it more
vertical and then
overlaid the original
image on the vertical image
so that the device became
proportionately right.
Happily, got the MIT
homepage highlight.
So that was nice.